[Music]
[Music]
what up y'all let up but I wanna have
you and say you guys we are continuing
our eight days of horror even though our
second day which was yesterday got
possessed by the tech tech demons and
made everything fall apart and then our
morning stream got pushed our afternoon
and and we are stuff so it's day three
alright they too got haunted and it's
gone Persia here Richie here if you guys
don't know up until Halloween we want to
try to play a bunch of spooky games and
kinda you know reach back into the
archive of like people's favorites I
turn to Twitter got a bunch of
recommendations from you guys and also
on our first day you guys sent us some
recommendations to so we have been
formulating the rest of our time until
Halloween so the evil within that is
what's happening today Ritchie and I
will be taking turns of the controller
or trying to get maximum spookiness so
we will see how it goes let's get this
started
starting from the beginning I am kind of
ready we're both in the same boat where
we played like right like barely any of
it so we're about to get spooked out
y'all yeah do you know there's the
second one but I hear that this one is
better so you guys can let me know your
opinion also because I did hear a few
people say that they thought two is
better I guess let us know Prince thing
keep that in mind for next year you know
but yes chat welcome I'm tangled odo
already oh wait yeah
yeah all right yeah that was spooky
casual hmm
standard I like going with standard yeah
yeah filagot I'm sorry I'm no vet but I
can do standard mode Oh
once the difficulty level is set that's
it that's it all right you guys hey
everyone what's up you guys that one
save us yeah it's about to get creepy in
here
it's creepy yet so sky well that makes
me feel better
enemies will search out any loud sounds
they hear well hopefully they can't hear
me screaming whenever we start
oh snap our boy Daniel from Poland is
that one a for copy code 3 eta three
minutes
[Applause]
but like looks good 2014 sounds serious
is it a riot I'm calling out just before
I picked you up said it was multiple
homicides you have a dozen units already
maybe it's the ghost of that doctor who
went schizo and chopped up all those
patients Oh Danes not what happened a
patient's disappeared
shut down that be real quick that still
gives you the creeps
Joseph you think there's a connection
it's a possibility
believe the records were sealed records
dispatch this is detective Castellanos
in 184 what's the situation
Jesus oh I like how long ago in the back
was unphased she was like whatever she's
chillin
alright chat I am I'm ready yeah I like
just move forward like I enjoy cutscenes
but like yeah I'm ready to get spooks
you know there is a lot more story
probably there so like we're unlimited
Simon if there's anything I learned from
the first stream like you need every
minute to really get the most out of the
horror again yeah we want the spooks now
so yeah rant master in the chat says
this is like my game have you ever been
have you never played this masterpiece
we have not so like we've had like like
small moments with it here and there but
we've wanted to like actually check it
out and enjoy it so here we go and do it
let's do it I bought it it was like the
last game I was just telling Persia like
one of the last games I bought for the
ps3 all right stay sharp
looks like I'm getting some Wesker vibes
right Robert says I feel safe if Richie
is around seeing this I was like Richie
again I'm on the sticks let's go
oh shoot a massacre look at this they
pointed the camera down for him yet I
want to be good feeling you've got there
goodness or something Josh said this
game is so good I was too scared to beat
it a nobody yeah how's the first hour
Josh that's about what we're gonna cut
away we're gonna get freaked out oh no
no no he just decided to wait until we
were right a slump oh really yeah
there's young Wesker are you injured
you're alive what happened here oh man I
was scared impossible
oh I've got it
the security cameras might tell us
something
Oh so I go alone well someone's got to
be here with that guy here we go
oh yeah can you activate subtitles that
might help yeah Kaiba says I can't wait
for evil within three is that gonna be a
thing I feel like I haven't heard
anything about that
no not graphics general was it here yeah
excellent let us see the words yeah
spooky words on tape seem at all so I'm
actually kind of cool yeah nope nope
like you could look that up okay oh the
controller Russell not cool
oh no he went like through the recording
in do those you what oh man the skin
real already that was real it actually
was really our captured yep oh we're
bleedin there's a rat now I'm probably
upside down some health concerns in this
hospital for sure Angel of Darkness says
this was the hardest platinum trophy I
ever achieve who got it is Oh yep I am
upside down absolutely
play that you don't want them gonna oh
that knife looks like we can take it out
of his body it's shimmering I can't even
I can't go for it I can only rotate the
camera Derrick's I said this game is
child's play in comparison to Resident
Evil 7 in VR ok I will enjoy VRS spooky
games are like you like highest tier of
spookiness
we should play Resident Evil 7 in VR do
you have any more no well we have a VR
set here oh I don't know how well that
would do for scream but even the regular
game is mm-hmm well we'll look into it
for sure first Wigan I can't oh man
there's like that tomb raider stuff is
the momentum do it before you hear me
right come on
gosh that time that reach oh my goodness
gonna slice your hand open keep it quiet
nope way too loud I'm probably gonna die
well you took that like a champ I didn't
hear no grunts no oh it's kind of a
stealth fall what the hell happened
nope I can I just turn around here you
go forgive me I was kind of just joking
out of cuz I'm scared
yeah I don't think I should approach
this guy haven't we got a knife there's
no way out always a little area over
here he's coming he's being come picked
up that body he's like I got a new
delivery and I need to get the F out of
here run homeboy nope oh my gosh no oh
of course
yeah thank you all who are one to sneak
[Music]
William said just talk to him I'm sure
he was reasonable Oh keep it going
Jackie cuz they're saving me you don't
even know okay he's going away
I need something the key I'm sure Eric
rter I would not know what sees you in
this situation in real life oh that's oh
yeah that would have been me okay so I
know how to sneak and that's about it
the hard truth Smith is effed up in this
game mm-hmm good to know
yes I braved Silent Hill 2 I literally
got scared of my own shadow in Silent
Hill 2 literally okay now should I like
I think we need the weights we like goes
in the back and then but like wish I do
get behind the table once he does look
around
yeah I think we have to hide it
somewhere okay and let him pass and then
and then run yeah oh that's a good idea
he won't when he comes back out I'll be
behind the table and he won't suspect
can you really not go in that chest to
your left
oh yes it looks like it looks like yeah
I'm not getting any options I'm gonna
get that are you are you interested you
know what you you figured out what
you're supposed to be right there at
least like get to the next room
okay how about we we should set a time
limit like every every fourth twenty
minutes or something all right you know
what to do now good evening from the UK
says Jay thanks for joining us thanks
for tuning in and getting spooked with
us yeah now we know what to do where you
guys are probably laughing at us but we
are learning we've died twice twice
honestly I feel like the forever like
impending doom I feel when I play really
hinders my thought process when it comes
to these games well good that's probably
what they're going for you like are you
like reverse ed not trying to that's
funny notice my keys are notice that the
keys again hurry up
dude I know just won't be like till T
Kim and everything yes
super-slow pieces Oh God so loud up and
away from this fool let's go this is
just two of many of us don't worry
thanks angels technique that sounds
about right
this is full speed which is good because
you're probably right below me and he'll
start here in fact yeah let's say were
they doing running around here dark say
them linen says graphics are pretty
awesome they are rain and this game came
out twenty play I tripped an alarm
oh they set me up he pulled out a cheese
what the hell where is some limp Biskit
[ __ ] right here I'm running for my
life he's trapped oh no this is a trap
full speed
good
what's worse like sliding around and
poop or being dead I don't know it
sounds pretty nice compared to that Ryan
said we're gonna lose count how many
does have rh @ you guys have to keep
count for us we're at two almost three
God you know that like that's not they
can't be the only guy here oh boy
because I find it hard to believe that
guy created all of this yeah he's like
the muscle yeah exactly
no I'm sliding around in other people's
blood with my blade all injured I know
you if you even if we survive this we
definitely caught something a big open
wound on the leg we just swam in a pool
of blood that came from somewhat or
somewhere nasty left or right left was
there was it more of a dead end hey but
there might be something over there a
key or health spray anything No
whoo okay glad we're we're away from
that I know my heart is racing and not
even out of like it being scary just
more the adrenaline of like oh I know I
have to pee again this is full speed and
I'm tempted to check over there but it's
gonna go yeah that's it it not today
that's not that is how I play though I
just explore every corner there's a door
let's check la no clock we're actually
playing this on ps4 for those of you
asking
strawberry yams it wasn't blood that's
what Alan says hey did you really
straight a walk up to the slumped over a
body and ask him where the exit was he's
got something oh man oh man okay I notes
you think his notes will help should I
look over them no no let's figure it out
and laugh at us okay
oh no I don't like this barbed wire door
only had a key or a gun lock door yep
yeah okay let's find a key huh
I'm limping this is bad news
right where the heels at yeah herbs
herbs spray both so dark
hey ladder oh snap can you look up y-yes
like I was like oh I'm like ducking in
my chair oh that's him I was like I hear
some breathing mm yeah that's probably
freaking out oh my god why do I feel
like this is the meet room we started in
I'm actually not sure if it's 60 FPS no
no I don't think it's meant to be cuz
it's it's like it looks more like a film
when it is in red folder
okay boiler room stuff gotcha
very early game stuff like man appears
oh it's probably that at 2:00 p.m.
oh damn who's 21 minutes ago no don't do
that to me Persia break it down over
here it's like 2:00 p.m. our time for
reals IRL
you can play this in full-screen - Oh
interesting
mmm like the cinematic the cinematics
going on it's been too quiet I know they
let you calm down just enough yeah that
was a good start though and I do
remember that okay mmm-hmm give me G
something let me look around
just follow even blood stains everywhere
no he's gonna find us yeah we can
breadcrumbs I am terrified something is
gonna frickin one of these drawers I'm
just waiting for an someone okay oh my
goodness start creeping
Oh gene saw no I think we need to get
into a locker I think I need to get that
F out of here I think that that you have
to be able to go into that line or what
are very mediately okay okay whew just
inside boy controller shook I'm shook
why would I want to exit all right am i
dying here no no we're good
William Garcia says I hate chainsaw so
much here same I get duck
oh oh we're good he's just throwing a
tantrum I think I need to get out of
here before you start this point oh my
god see they were testing our like
nerves of steel right there
goodness you're like maybe I knew to run
no no it's the bull Locker he's still
around though here okay no should we go
back the way we came
I want to see where I've been cuz he
might have opened the door um all right
let me I just want him I want the sound
to go farther away go back the way I
came okay yeah okay he's in there why
would I go that way uh he sounds very
far though I don't know which one other
way to go we got a checkpoint why don't
we dip it out hello oh is it just you
I saw him sneak behind ever oh wait
something he's singing good yeah he's
doing his rounds
[Music]
he's looking for me I want him to leave
like okay you know what I said what I
said we have a checkpoint yes that's the
water over here can't let him see me no
[ __ ]
yeah Rosie though I hear that too
there's never Walker oh good oh man
blocked off it's okay he might roll
through and destroy those boxes for us
that'd be nice oh there's another Walker
over there okay so we just got a locker
hop yeah
okay he's far away over there we're good
body size basic I have to get over there
I'm sure
oh my gosh okay this little cubby though
I do it yeah I can probably dodge them
using games oh well here they live in
light on the 800 a bottle oh that's the
bus style where should I throw it I need
to go over there oh shoot right there
okay I have a plan how to chuck this
though cuz I need is a beer ooh you know
why don't I just not use the bottle oh
man oh this isn't good
nope you're in the open yes I'm still
limping when will this end can I close
the door why sorry I don't want him to
see me through these windows in case he
hasn't seen me I'm like ducking into my
chair this is not cool I know I'm like
we're good we close the dark
is there another locker in here just so
we know okay check Oh boom that's suck
where's that this looks
can I have medicine please my leg
can I get one of these wheelchair
shadows terrified oh no I gotta like
parkour over this thing
that's all my boy were like in real life
same oh thank goodness for that quick
closing door yeah take the stairs loser
what I need answers but I know right we
just woke up and this was a damn mess
homeboy caught us through the screen put
us here I'm all messed up
all right good job lady
creepy he's the intro yeah shall we
press on yes yeah
first Aurora can win
okay you know what they're giving us a
moment to catch our breath yeah so while
we go through this I noticed in the chat
some people were using ghost wire Tokyo
got canceled really oh really because if
so that's really unfortunate for me
wasn't that the one where the the one
presenter she was like that would be
unfortunate because that actually look
really cool I don't want to misspeak I
think I saw something where like that
lady left okay yeah I saw that too maybe
you started falling down afterwards I
hope not I know don't have like another
PT thing okay are you ready yes y'all
see the fun thing about like games like
this is that they're not like stressful
controls so we can do no yeah this
controls I figured out pretty easily
it's not nothing crazy so far alright I
can right now my leg as yield my buddy
run for your life the lobby knock it
out of here four doors lead to TV
nothing give me I guess it is alright
she's falling apart
yep it's a damn earthquake over here Oh
Paul says peachy will haunt us forever
yeah especially what could have what it
could have been you know oh no this is
bigger than just the hospital but the
whole world is literally being taken
over
since our ride out of here let's go you
know
oh I ain't getting in that oh okay get
out good wait let me in okay
for real okay so this is interesting
not one of those ones are you like in
one building the whole time no we left
that building right away win some meat
hey that guy's awakened okay the one on
the left by the way maybe it's us we
should have left her remaining wait she
called
William Garcia if only the rock is here
yeah all of this like a helicopter
oh my god
oh man
Sam violence is real
I hope all ambulance service fast in
case I need it
I'm terrible yeah real Oh is this
building sliding or
oh the hole this is stressful
today yeah the rock would know what to
do he was in San Andreas with me
well that happens
yeah did
no come on first it was just about ready
to play I know I'm about to skip this
let's be dead
we're on limited time I'm sorry you guys
okay great yeah next chapter with your
breathe right noise okay it's loading
yeah giving us a few moments here yeah
what's up everybody
Cabo in the channel Oh DRT how do you
say that hi hello hello what is that B
is Daniel yo oh man we got captured
again see what we don't watch the
cutscene yeah we lost all context end up
and I am moving us around but it's still
giving me an option to skip which is
awesome that's okay it was gonna kind of
help that I cut skip the cutscene cuz it
made it like drop right into it
all right I get it um captured I'm all
dizzy oh my life is low once again now
my stomach hurt my leg was hurting now
my stomach hurts and you're being
watched in third person I know it's like
security cam footage oh they left me
some medicine though there we go oh I
want to throw up in that toilet but
there's something shiny in here more
health really in there okay take where
we can get it I guess some light in here
huh
all right let's investigate oh yeah
that's uh
sanitary Oh reminds me of Metal Gear
Solid when you're stuck in the little
cell for real
up pretty sure she's a ghost
Oh yep because she gon finessed she's
out at least she opened the door for us
this place is necessary for you oh yes
you're always welcome here I've been
hospitalized we also think we
time-traveled also there was a
phonograph for the right without signing
there is no way to ensure your future
matters Maurice oh oh yes saved alright
mmm this way please
smells like medicine
interesting since of smelly you had it
are bad
neo chair from the matrix or Morpheus
chair please
have a seat what was that symbol like a
lobotomy definitely a lobotomy you
mustn't fight it this is for your own
good
this is a nasty way to upgrade your
skills okay Oh completely yes
oh now you're about to be in straightest
well I am just getting bodied in every
which way
oh the dream back IRL Marcelo says this
is a good old game 15 yeah so far pretty
damn exciting was going on where am i
it's walking another creepy woods trail
are you gotta follow the blood it's
everyone's leave all right good I got
scared see I'm too jumpy for this looks
like he had a bad trip yeah definitely
did spooky Birds check blood everywhere
Oh attack enemies fair hit nice cuz
she's had a dead creature finally we can
defend ourselves I'm glad it took us all
this time to learn how to throw here I
don't know where I'm going this looks
like we've lost the blood trail oh yeah
I don't even know if we were supposed to
that we found it cuz it led to that
thing but now where do we go I see some
light over here yes
Oh lightning time okay you can see oh
hell no what a ruining like what is he
eating
I think yep look at the hands I feel
like I might need that later her friend
the driver our pal Connolly
Wow those taken straight out of Resident
Evil 1 that's great yes stronger teeth
okay maybe not the the most opportune
time to learn about the gun or did you
do that oh okay I thought it was the
game you got it for me okay and oh I did
not get it come on men Daniel asks we
played this game before this is about as
far as I go I didn't get too much
farther after this that was a head shot
yes so bleeding okay short answers Oh
Daniel no not really a little bit that
was it my god after four bullets the
things what are these things yeah I'm
gonna make me inspect the body give you
some more bullets that'd be nice I know
right Connelly we're done bullets at
where'd you go actually
oh boy um yeah a questionable cave
where's my lantern today oh man awesome
is that
mhm yeah unless I can get a new one from
yeah what's this light source brain fuel
hands yeah Alan that was pretty much I'm
pretty sure it was the intentional
reference to Resident Evil 1 because the
same director started this series of
games she's in the Connie
Oh L oh there's another guy just sitting
there menacingly
note do we know you have to say no I
like it
oh is it true it's the person from our
ambulance were you warning me about this
you are Lesley right I'm a police
officer
maybe I should help you how am I gonna
get you to a hospital see his body
okay what the [ __ ] yeah well that's what
we're thinking just said what we were
thinking
oh you know we can go under it okay we
acquired it good yeah might be able to
set up our own traps later wait oh wait
you'll Leslie's stop playing around girl
or boy
I actually don't know Paul says this is
a Shinji inception because they're both
because he saw that reference from
Resident Evil 1 I'm really I'm not
looking forward to win I have 200 bring
the bodies they come why use my one of
two matches I just picked up great Oh
creepy outhouse
with blood on the door
[Applause]
why is she guys up here like that look
at all these bloody tools and now he's
mascara to the room no oh the bloody
shoe and a glowing book I thought this
was yeah I read that
[Music]
we're back that's some Claire de Lune in
here I don't like that William he's like
time to heat things up I think he knows
something's going on something's about
to happen oh no I'm back
oh man back here again oh yeah I must be
losing it
oh wait hey Bryan okay where's the way
the door was open okay
we're making a little more progress this
time I don't know if that was a bad
dream or this is he's asking all the
right questions you again I know with
your Bayonetta glasses she does look
like being alright there's another
mirror we kind of travel it here through
there oh yeah you're right there way out
what is the truth Persia what's going on
okay okay we can go there's a portal
yeah yes we are all scared for noise
Oh
the door also creaking the music is
still playing though
well it's fading away you're eating the
ominous stuff now Cabo kibo I can't that
guide right here right now but there are
guides on YouTube on how to do that for
sure I had to look it up myself oh
there's a guy here okay I was like yeah
maybe can you punch him I don't know
whatever you want to do you are in the
driver's seat person oh the night oh boy
alright so one knife shot to the head
does the trick but on four bullets to
the face I know you felt like a finesse
I wish he had like a cigarette to it
just blow it out on him another creepy
outhouse bathroom thing Oh Leslie
escaped come on
Oh oh yeah you know stealth going
through the trees and why not fire boy
go check creepy forest check cemetery
[Music]
is closing on me right now that is
creepy
oh I don't like the look of that guy no
shoes hey are you guys from around here
I don't know this guy I have a feeling
this guy will not be helpful at all
[Music]
Oh Oh No
well yeah oh oh my god I don't have
enough ammo for this oh boy okay get him
away from here
wizard unfortunately we're playing after
at the regular difficulties we what the
hardest difficulty wasn't unlocked and I
don't think would be good enough to pull
it off my bottle it didn't work lousy
bottle I'm like I only have two bullets
this guy's pretty chill oh oh my god
it's that legs that leg of yours
no no if I was supposed to go in there
or not oh I think Leslie's over here
there's a topless guy over there that's
not cool already done
I think remember you can sneak with ya
they're they're not you're off the radar
nice switch shoulders that would be
useful video Oh
tall grass I know like how strong am i I
hope your knife doesn't like overtime
doesn't look like it still kill what's
one I have no matches those oh I wonder
how long it'll take for him to yeah
maybe get up I assume that's why you
like them on fire don't get smart on me
now
ok Beebo go ahead man Cabo tell me your
ps4 supported game let's hear it
William says I get so exhausted playing
these games they're fun but the fear is
draining does he see you maybe not
I'm rotting here right I'm out of here
you're my old man legs moving get that
stamina up you did it slap oh I guess I
was supposed to not do that what honey
you have to man I don't know maybe you
check a bottle and get them far away I
don't know that's all I can think of I
think I was supposed to stop kill them
and yeah maybe we're like great me
you're back on there ok
oh you got to kill the I know mr. clean
says oh yeah go ahead and leave some F's
in the chat for that one we were
learning together here ok Mario Magnus
says we should do evil within to next
also the first-person mode was fantastic
I did see that in the when I was evil
like picking games oh oh and I saw that
there was a first-person mode in the
second one which I feel like
first-person just adds a whole nother
level
Jonas had you shook the bottle have you
thrown i'm aimed and then I did the
trigger thing ok
will that attract everyone hmm nope not
this guy not the guy get out of the way
he's death you shoulda saved
oh you're right okay I'm gonna do what
you did try to try to bring the brain
okay joven said right in the kisser pick
up the toys yeah oh yeah you bite you
bite right or the bottle trip wire nope
you only got one available hand
apparently hey whoa would you what would
you take did you just duck under this i
disarmed it that was much a much cooler
way of taking care of that trip oh great
okay that's death number four mr. clean
likes this game more than the second one
cool glad you're here with us today
friend okay I'm gonna save this bottle
or can I take that knife out of that
guy's head that'd be great
I don't want to test that yeah my name
is cool but that one you got there yeah
looks like it would come in real handy
like a machete in your head daniel said
brah William favorite Dana's respects
right now myself to high heaven he was
resting in pieces oh no I hate you
yeah but he's sort of gave up oh he's
ready oh crap wait you're an old man
don't run too far oh no you're gonna
have to run a little faster that played
sucker
yeah okay close the door and phone me
all right no no he's chasing your ass no
he wished he whipped it all right so
these homeboys oh that's why you need
the torch good burn the bodies don't go
yet
okay go get that torch and burn those
bodies on the ground okay take all the
way here I believe in you okay how do
you throw hands
weii bean triangle okay too many
different consoles in my brain there you
go back your head oh I love that all
right so um I don't think throwing hands
is that effect no I need yeah I need the
stealth moves you want to go again
all right you're good at the stealth I I
just got word from gamespot HQ that we
have to wrap up at 3:15 which is 15
minutes shorter than what we anticipated
so we're gonna we are we got this we got
this baby
no areas at least you see you thought to
think you thought of the torch like
that's gonna push us ahead for sure hey
when they run with a lady oh I tried to
dodge roll cuz I don't think gotta work
one to the head go for thus we now know
we are dead done I was like why are we
so much stronger and smarter than me I'm
a human they're dead
Oh press X repeatedly to recovery went
quickly
thanks game they were like it was
struggling yeah I feel like normally
those tips those in game tips kind of
stink that one was helpful
alright so we can get this guy I just
got a great go on taking the scenic
route
make sure real stealthy kill ugly
angel of darkness told you this game is
hard yeah oh yeah hopefully you're
enjoying the flail though look over
there
yeah go away there's nothing over here
clearly oh yeah that's for earlier yeah
exactly
and I'm gonna take your torch are we
gonna go burn your homies Oh see I was
like got this the gate is the goal
another one you're right
good eye you what cool
what if that's the end of him oh forget
about this trip who sets these then I
know they're bait from the freakin smart
very convenient they just die there all
right okay yeah what was that I don't
like loud noises I don't see ya that
sounded like an explosion maybe from
that person oh yeah that's right I think
you accidentally o'night it someone but
boy don't know me oh you boys
still alive oh no there's more where you
go that sounded good there you go
William we do play horror games versus
just kind of getting into them I think
she said recently I've been playing I
play mostly survival horror when it
comes to the horror genre
this is one I played a little bit but
not very much so we do play them for
entertainment on our own but this one
was exciting because we both had it
really alright I've lured them away
they're slow I can you do it I can do
this oh my god we're not gonna get past
the stupid gate Ritchie is that Regina
no we have time we have time you can do
this Persia
I think it's oh no we're learning it's
all about planning yeah actually when I
kicked that guy on the floor I was
trying to set them up oh right yeah I
was waiting for that option to torch
them but you just kick them in the face
much better by the way yeah I've only
like all them pistol whips noted zombies
are invulnerable to pistol whips Paul
says Burnham already thugs out there
you're not gonna survive in a zombie
apocalypse yeah now without bullets mm
this guy Haram we both have tried a
little bit of evil within we didn't get
very far which was a coincidence cuz but
yeah but no we haven't finished this
game or anything so we're learning along
the way I'm starting to feel like maybe
I was playing too when I play cuz I
definitely played one cuz I remember
that changed all guy oh nice oh and a
punch oh you know what I know what I was
supposed to do again
I gotta lure them to the trap oh cool
he boom wait well there was 300 that guy
got caught in the third one right now
you just yeah I left those there can i
Reece off
really oh crap I just body myself should
I go die real quick I don't know
everyone appears to be gone there's
another this guy's gonna run into it oh
yeah he's handling bro come at me bro
cool can we finally take that knife out
of his head okay we turned into bits and
this zombie I don't know drop an elbow
down I love that kick it's like dead
space actually that's better than the
dead space dead space is like the stomp
he just wailed on him
I only wanted to set those guys on fire
oh man these two Oh
hey TC I wish bear chats up yeah
they're the only two left though after
these you can you can open the gate yeah
I'm gonna try to lure them all the way
up Oh No that dumb guy from earlier hey
they don't see oh the gate is yes do you
big gate in my way you know what kill me
just kill me
losers Oh kill me now I'm gonna make you
guys run into the bear trap yeah we'll
leave them open you guys will die there
I know these clearly they're way too
freakin smart for them hmm
okay that one we know all right we got
this
first I'm gonna take out homeboy over
here right step one step one
did he seem optional Oh angel darkness
if there's a [ __ ] that has matches in it
him how you slip in did you have
something on him oh yeah the torch oh oh
hey yo that's some HP back stuff of life
over here yeah hello yeah now you don't
see me huh
I heard him oh yeah yeah [ __ ] you stay
there oh yeah matches maybe in here
oh I'm gonna win all the way around
why Hey this tractor bottle
with him he says that some elder scrolls
max sneaking skills on fire now
hopefully it'll burn them both hey Jesse
what up there you go your yep oh they
stopped noticing you Oh anybody I don't
want at me neither
Oh someone set up the trap in there all
right that's how we were supposed to do
it y'all success yes that we'd learned
see I wanted to throw hands so bad it
was fun I kick expression when you learn
to kick them on the wall they're down
that's great
it should be one guy laughing very far
away
if you make it now I saw one more trap
actually move to the side nice we did it
and we have 10 minutes left and now
we're stuck
yeah there's a lot to explore you a
checkpoint I'm not like we made that
harder than anything go oh okay check
that stamina doing what you're doing
living put running for my life you gotta
just keep doing that
there we go now we're making sense that
should have been the first thing you
said trying to conserve me you're
standing that's good smart run walk you
know oh this is not yeah oh gosh
Oh
oh oh oh oh no my hand alone okay good
timing
they're like ants daya okay they gave up
trapper to clear nicely done oh yes
all right would you play this alone I
feel like so far yes because there are
scary moments but it's not like so
terrifying it's not like when I remember
playing like the beginning of fear where
like there's each other like every few
seconds so yeah now we have a few
minutes left but I feel like if we start
another chapter it's gonna be higher you
know we'll try to get as far as we can
to the next chapter in the next like
five minutes okay fair enough
cuz I feel like at the beginning of
every chapter that it was like all the
good stuff it was like I'll be good yeah
you know we got a few minutes let's just
see me go me okay Oh what's a mystical
nisha welcome back good to see ya
unfortunately we're about to wrap up
soon what do you think you have any
plans for tomorrow's Horror stream are
we gonna wait that reveal I mean I have
a bunch of things on the docket so I
think what did I have set up some things
on the menu it means
necessarily be tomorrow exactly but I do
a sphere on there and I've Dead Sea's
three on there on the list right now
what else is on the list I saw this
Linderman the arrival game and I know
generally like the Slender Man like folk
war whatever is kind of creepy to me so
yeah I wanted to check that out even
though I never heard of it before
I brought some cuz I was in that boat
also I never played those like those
really popular like Slenderman or Misha
or things like that but I downloaded the
amnesia collection on my ps4 to try to
get into it but I never did but I also
brought Dead Space 1 and two money same
bang and of course Resident Evil 7 scary
that's cool they haven't really played
those games either because if you pick
them we'll both be in for a treat
because I don't know what I'm doing just
kind of like today but it worked out Wow
I think for the next streams will do
that did not the creeks open Maya I'm
assuming the wing did that
exactly
yeah I'm gonna try to aim for a little
bit like longer streams for the upcoming
spooky streams just because I feel like
it takes a while for the spooky games to
really ramp up yeah unless we like jump
chapters which we don't want to do
always got an axe yeah
thank goodness oh yeah I put until dawn
on the docket I've played mana Madan but
I haven't played until John and man
Amazon actually spook me a couple of
really really good times so disarmed
[Music]
merrily you were almost pieces again
yeah what maybe I should have let that
blow up cuz look what's behind there
looks like some potion can i no I'll
just take it with me yeah Oh getting
away from that some fire here we go this
is what eyes on thank you yay whoo Angel
of Darkness said until dawn is full way
go emoji yeah huh was always nasty food
in these games well yeah that's probably
what the zombies eat they can't find
brains we know Oh creaky doors right
those create a barn doors hmm a lot
to unpack here mentally taking this in
yeah I'm just gonna go to this little
house next to the spikes okay this do
not waste the axe oh just the axe
deteriorate over time you know what we
have a few minutes I'm gonna waste this
ass but that's good to know like oh is
this a safe room I think so oh there see
if it wants you but we just see no good
oh thanks for the tip now do I have
those potions head away okay no I think
I use the only syringe we had that's
okay we're winding down but I found that
green stuff outside I just know how to
use this stuff yeah oh we've got a lot
of it I don't know what to do with it
yet okay I'm gonna disarm this thing yes
quickly again just right there you guys
on your toes oh my gosh oh wait I can
collect that thing we're going for the
Attic go for it
gotta go to the creepy attic where human
words oh were hiding now abandon what no
I just wanted to I'm okay coming out of
here someone was asking for helping we
just hid under a bed I know
I'm coming help who's there Oh earlier
one of them I'm a doctor Marcelo Jimenez
you already know ambulance before yeah
yeah maybe not chicks house my patient
yesterday I saw him running up ahead I
come this way
like this where a look for yourself
those things chased me all the way into
the village me too they're all over the
place and there are lived that's right
he got through the game we did there are
too many to shoot our way through ok
good as you know you're the one with the
gun good we have no bullets and they're
like super durable they eat like four
shots yeah I'm not the wases doctor for
that dumb information where you go
actually we can't even continue on
unfortunately no no I'm not doing your
work no more no more sorry guys we have
to in the stream now but I had a lot of
fun with this I'm gonna try to play some
more of it and we got more spooky games
on the way we have like not including
today it thinks six more days until
Halloween and yeah I'm gonna try to aim
for our future spooky streams to be
longer so we can actually get more
scared every intro ever you know yeah
exactly so I hope that you guys enjoyed
sticking around with us today and tune
in for our other spooky streams we got a
lot of good recommendations in the chat
today and a lot of other stuff on the
menu until Halloween so please come on
back we actually have a lot of streams
plan for the next few weeks both in the
morning and in the afternoon so come
come around 11:00
or 2 p.m. is either gonna be one of them
yeah but I'll try to keep you guys
posted
I know I know the chat is like oh no no
that's fine I'm like feeling the same
way but it was fun thank you guys so
much for tuning in and we will catch you
guys later happy Wednesday
[Music]